The Victorian Moustache Cup
Beyond being a staple of any self-respecting
peace officer, thanks to the popularity of
things like Movember, the humble moustache
has made a glorious, bristly return to the
faces of men all over the world in recent
years.
As a result, there is an almost endless supply
of moustache related products one can buy,
which means it’s only a matter of time until
the moustache cup once again becomes relatively
commonplace.
“What’s a moustache cup”, you say?
The moustache cup is a cup designed with a
small lip on the inside intended to protect
the drinker’s face fuzz from whatever beverage
they happen to be drinking.
Despite sounding like the kind of joke gift
you’d get a moustachioed co-worker for secret
Santa because you don’t know them that well,
the moustache cup was something people took
very seriously once upon a time and it’s
noted that pretty much every self-respecting
gentlemen in the mid-to-late Victorian England
with a mouthbrow owned at least one.
If you’ve ever taken a glance at portraits
from the 19th century, you’re probably aware
that huge moustaches were very popular with
gentlemen of the era.
In fact, from 1860-1916, the British military
actually required all of its soldiers to sport
a moustache for the authority it imparted
to the moustachioed man.
Not surprisingly from this, gentlemen ultimately
came up with a number of ways to make sure
that their lip warmers were as gloriously
trimmed and maintained as possible.
One of the more popular ways to style a moustache
during this time was to use wax, some men
also liked to dye their moustache to give
it a more vibrant appearance.
The problem with both of these methods of
moustache maintenance was that neither held
up well to hot liquid- dye would run and wax
would invariably melt and cause unsightly
moustache droopage the second it came into
contact with something like hot tea or coffee.
Enter the moustache cup which is generally
thought to have been invented by an English
potter named Harvey Adams sometime between
1850 and 1860.
The moustache cup allowed a magnificently
moustachioed man to safely sip on a cup of
steaming tea without it getting wet or contaminating
his tea.
So when Adams first introduced the moustache
cup in Staffordshire, they proved to be a
hit with the social elite, causing a wave
of copycat products to hit the market.
Although moustache cups are also known to
have been very popular across the pond, finding
a surviving specimen with a “made in America”
mark on it is incredibly rare.
This is not so much a reflection on their
popularity in America, but because early American
manufacturers would commonly falsely claim
that the cups they produced had been made
in England due to the high demand for English
ceramics in the states at the time.
Surviving left-handed moustache cups are also
noted to be very hard to find and even when
the popularity of the cup was at its peak,
left-handed individuals usually had to make
do with a portable moustache guard that could
be fitted onto either side of an ordinary
cup.
By the turn of the 20th century, the invention
of the safety razor led to a change in grooming
habits that made moustache cups obsolete for
the vast majority of men.
As a result, production and sales of moustache
cups slowly dried up.
By 1930, this formerly commonplace item was
almost unheard of.